bonjour monsieur merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur ert france la france qui
vient donc de s'offrir le plus gros
contrat d'armement de son histoire plus
de 16 milliards d'euros pour 80 rafale
c'est une victoire pour la france ou
pour les émirats arabes unis
c'est des relations commerciales
concernant le dossier de l'armement tant
que l si ces pays là vont pas acheter de
l'armement de la france ils vont trouver
le trouver ailleurs il peut faire des
contrats avec la russie avec la chine
avec le royaume uni bien évidemment avec
les états unis dont ils ont certainement
une dépendance stratégique maintenant il
n'ya pas que l'armement il ya aussi ces
de l'armement accompagné par de la
formation et par le conseil si on veut
parler de cette question d'art moment je
crois que la décision ne doit pas être
seulement décision réciproque entre deux
pays mais ça doit être aussi une
décision des nations unies c'est à dire
que c'est l'onu qui doit représenter
clairement les conditions de vente
d'armement il peut être même mettre des
sanctions contre certains certains pays
mais le fait qu'il ya des ong qui qui
sont contre ce genre de contrat d'un
moment ça je le comprends parfaitement
surtout comparé à 2,2 me larcher qui
sont pas démocratiques mais la question
aussi qui s'impose c'est aussi la
question de commerce international dans
l'armement devient un élément très
considérable surtout que pour le cas
français là maintenant on est en train
de récompenser en fin de compte le
contrat perdu avec l'australie alors
justement la france qui va voir ses
exportations d'armes en 2021 pulvérisé
le record de 2015 vous l'avez dit paris
est vivement critiqué justement pour ces
contrats de défense ces armes qui sont
vendus ont une orientation bien
évidemment
la coalition de l'arabie saoudite avec
la gare ou yémen mais aussi en libye est
ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
finalement paris entretient peut-être
une une relation un petit peu à double
tranchant avec ces monarchies du golfe
non moi je crois qu'il ya une volonté du
président macron de marquer une nouvelle
nouvelle politique au moyen-orient dans
ce cas on a déjà commencé l'année
dernière avec la visite de libre cette
année la visite du bar date qui était
très intéressante si et là maintenant il
ya la visite des monarchies du golfe
dont l'objectif est très clair d'abord
la question de la stabilité régionale
c'est à dire le fait de parler de la
libye de la syrie l'irak le yémen mais
aussi la question de la lutte contre le
terrorisme la france a besoin de ces
pays pour financer des coalitions soit
au sahel ou même aussi pour collaborer
avec les afghans s'est parfaitement par
exemple la relation forte du qatar avec
certains organisation islamiste radicale
parce que dans le monde ou même aussi en
afghanistan en particulier et il
troisièmement c'est le dossier
économique sa der le fait de ne chercher
pas seulement des contrats d'armement
mais aussi chercher des contrats pour
les grandes entreprises françaises il
faut rappeler aussi que l' échange
commercial entre la france et ces trois
pays concernés par cette visite sa
voisine à peu près 20 milliards d'euros
donc avec une raison si de 700
entreprises françaises donc là on a
montré un petit peu l'ampleur de ce
marché extrêmement important surtout
qu'on parle de trois pays très influent
dans la scène politique du monde arabe
parce que avant certainement avant le
printemps arabe il y avait des rats
qu'il y avait de la série avait à
l'egypte qui décide en quelque sorte le
destin du monde arabe là maintenant il
ya un changement radical dans sa tête
dans cette région d'abord avec la manne
financière importante chez ces trois
pays et deuxièmement c'est la nouvelle
génération des dirigeants dans ce dans
les trois pays je parle de l'arabie
saoudite
aux émirats et aussi le
mohammad ben salman qui va d'ailleurs
recevoir emmanuel macron peut-être un
petit peu pour briser la glace après
bien évidemment la faire rage aux gays
aujourd'hui l'elysée dit que finalement
la france cherche un petit peu a
contribué à la stabilité de la région
que ce soit de la méditerranée jusque
justement dans les pays du golfe est ce
que vous êtes du même avis
battu d'abord certainement il ya une
menace qui est très intéressante pour
les pour les pays concernés par cette
visite c'est l'expansionnisme iranien
c'est le comportement de l'iran dans
cette région donc les proxys de liron
soit le hezbollah au liban ont bien leur
outil ou e-mail ou d'autres d'autres
mouvements en syrie il ya en irak menace
la stabilité de seuil des six monarchies
aussi le dossier nucléaire qui est
extrêmement compliqué est toujours en
cours de négociation avec avec les
américains maintenant ce genre de pays
et samson en plus menacée parce qu'il ya
aussi un désengagement un repli
américain de la région du moyen orient
bien sûr ça ouvre la porte à plusieurs
acteurs de marquer certaines présences
notamment la france n'y a pas que la
france il ya la russie aussi la chine
qui est un des principaux fournisseurs
de tête et d'armement pour ces pays
c'est le premier fournisseur de dettes
pour le koweit par exemple les poux
romain et c'est également le premier
partenaire commercial pour le qatar et
les émirats arabes unis avec des projets
très intéressants notamment la route de
la soie donc ça bien sûr c'est les
relations en plein compétitivité la
france maintenant veut marquer une
position c'est-à-dire le fait de
chercher des intérêts économiques mais
en même temps le fait de chercher aussi
l'influencé politique parce que c'est
très important pour la position
française est classique historique même
moment et lorient merci beaucoup en tout
cas à younes belle fait là d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant en relations
internationales et spécialiste du monde
arabe